[Musique]
au palais de justice de vesoul
un jeune père de famille va comparaître
il lui est reproché des violences
conjugales
un dossier sur trois en haute saône
après sa garde à vue il a été déféré
devant le procureur avant de se
retrouver à la barre du tribunal
qu'est ce que c'est qu'ils avaient
appelé la police non d'accord alors
qu'ils vivent les voisins et pourquoi
les voisins appellent la police mal
parce que ça crie très fort d'accord
peut-être parce qu'ils sont inquiets
quand il ya des grosses disputes
est-ce qu'on vous schiffman est ce qu on
vous tire les cheveux et pour les autres
formes
le 14 septembre le 20 décembre il se
passe rien mais les voisins appellent la
police met pas victimes vous êtes une
victime
peut-être que vous l'acceptez pas je pas
voulu poser de questions pour vous
mettre pas vous mettre en difficulté
mais vous êtes une victime et une
relation de couple anormal il semble que
par le passé mais également fait l'objet
d'une petite violence de paf je mens 2
condamné une peine de 12 mois
d'emprisonnement et surtout bien sûr
nous délivrons un dépôt 'cela fait
drôlement a rigolé lorsque l'on voit et
cris et pleurs
la mise à jour vers moi quand je pleure
j'ai aussi le visage rouge et ce n'est
pas pour autant que j'ai pris un coup
mais n'avons absolument aucun élément
puisque madame ici présente bien vous
dit non mais moi j pas reçu de claques
j'ai pas reçu de violence nous nous
sommes disputés
oui viola dans cette affaire le
procureur a requis de la prison ferme
ils plaident dans l'intérêt de la
société de son bon fonctionnement
c'est la principale mission du ministère
public qu'il représente mais c'est bien
le tribunal qui aura le dernier mot
vous êtes donc monsieur déclaré de
coupables
et trois chefs de poursuite de ces trois
délits en répression monsieur compte
tenu de votre personnalité de votre
casier judiciaire des faits qui sont
graves
vous êtes condamné monsieur à la peine
de 10 mois d'emprisonnement
vous partez immédiatement en prison à la
maison d'arrêt de dijon
la criminal des fermes amanda donnez
vous à votre encontre
c'est un miroir de notre société que
nous découvrons dans les murs de ce
tribunal en 2018 ce sont plus de 13
mille six cents procédures qui ont été
transmises et traitée par le parquet de
la haute saône un tiers ont donné lieu à
des poursuites a rendez vous avec la
justice
empreint de colère de désespoir et
souvent de souffrance
le métier de procureurs faire de maistre
du parquet était médecin et sont assez
proches vous êtes un médecin de l'âme
malheureusement ce que vous avez ce que
vous voyez ce que vous entendez ici
c'est tous les drames de nos sociétés on
a rarement des bonnes nouvelles
lorsqu'on juge ces personnes lorsqu'on
les défaire on rentre effectivement dans
l'humain on rentre dans l'intimité de
vie que personne ne connaît hormis nous
c'est pour ça que ce métier attire
énormément ces métiers qui sont très
riches en ce sens la journée se poursuit
à l'extérieur cette fois direction gré à
une heure de route de vesoul un
distributeur de billets a été attaqué à
l'explosif en plein centre ville
il faut comprendre et surtout rassuré
est aussi une marque par rapport à la
population parce que c'est quand même un
événement tout peut choquer en plein
coeur de ville de faire sauter les
distributeurs explosif on est sur une
équipe criminels quand même assez
préoccupante
[Musique]